may god bless
all right wow i was going to wait
another 10 minutes or so before jumping
on here but
there's there's 6 000 people already
waiting for me you guys must have been
looking for some other stream and
accidentally uh click clicked onto mine
i can't
imagine uh that that is deliberate it is
uh
it's over folks it's over the weekend is
over and we are back
uh back at full speed now and through
the election
donald trump's taxes have been published
by the new york times full video clip
coming up in 53 minutes on my youtube
channel trump
uh paid zero federal taxes 10 of the
last 15 years he owes 300 million to
various
creditors uh in loans that come due in
the next few years a total debt of 420
million dollars for donald trump who
does he owe it to
we don't know how does this connect with
donald trump campaign
uh money laundering allegations to the
tune of 170 million dollars
i think the two things are probably
related
how does this all relate to trump's
former campaign campaign manager brad
parscale
um threatening to kill himself and being
barricaded in his house and taken
yesterday by law enforcement
it's par scales company that the money
is allegedly being laundered through
so i believe all of the these things are
uh connected in some way shape or form
but alas i've already recorded my
thoughts about that in a clip that we'll
be publishing to
youtube at the top of the hour we are
here for
an update on coronavirus or as donald
trump says you know there's about 19
names for it many of which i don't use
but you know them
um that's at the bottom of the hour this
was originally scheduled for 2 pm
at 2 p.m i was a no and then
at that's why it still says 2 p.m here
in the pbs thing
it is it was rescheduled to 3 30 the
bottom of the hour
and as you can see this is the white
house feed
i'm always up for other feeds it's not
clear
i don't know if fox news has a feed we
could maybe pick up as well
sometimes they uh you know we see what's
going on in the room or in the rose
garden let's see
trump live see if there are any other
feeds not looking like it right now
not seeing it let's just filter by live
just to take one more look
bloomberg no that's something else
department of state is the same as the
white house
uh this can't what is this this is weird
this isn't going on right now i wonder
what that's all about in any case we're
standing by for
i have so many things to talk to you
guys about though so i'm glad you're
here
you whoa i don't know why don jr is up
on screen we're going to get away from
that
we have tomorrow night the first
presidential debate between donald j
trump and joseph
r biden jr our coverage will start at 8
30 pm eastern time tomorrow night 5 30
p.m pacific
i hope you will join me i really do i'm
hoping it will be
in practical terms our biggest stream
ever that's tomorrow night
i want to say thanks to everybody
gifting subscriptions on twitch and
signing up as you can see we've
pathetically
it's a major embarrassment actually we
have urgently
dropped below a thousand subscribers on
twitch
because they just ex you know they
expire some expire every day
and we are at our lo this is a low point
for us on twitch it really is but we're
gonna continue on and as many of you
know we have surpassed
a 50 000 followers on twitch now i do
have a very exciting piece of data
from the standpoint of youtube which is
depending on what happens today tomorrow
and wednesday which are the last three
days of september
um we are conceivably going to have
30 million views this month on youtube
now that
seems like it's a lot per day let me see
if i can do the math here 30 million
divided by 30 days
okay 3 divided by 3 is just a 1. so that
i'm clear on
then uh 0 divided by 0 that's a zero
zero zero divided by zero zero carry the
zero
zero well hold on thirty oh no i forgot
to carry i forgot
30 million divided by 30 what 30 million
a million views a day that's what it
would be if we actually get it which
would be amazing it would be a
our biggest month ever on youtube
actually so a lot of very
exciting things and it's all going to be
good for you in the long run
unless you want to see us fail in which
case it won't be quite so good
but if you like what we do it should all
be very very good
a couple of super chats coming in um
chaka seki says the only certain things
in life are death taxes and cob fe45
obfuscating for dear life to prevent us
from finding
who is funding his bloated diaper
yeah trump deducted 70 grand for hair
styling one year but nothing in there
about
diapers at all so i don't i don't know
about that chukaseki
um a kinky turtle has subscribed with
prime with the message
steven kenneth destiny bonnell ii sent
me
kedara has subscribed with the message
really enjoying your show
strongly david thank you for your
platform i appreciate that
um how to send a super chat so super
chat is youtube only
and it's the dollar sign either at the
bottom of the chat window on desktop
or sort of as an overlay to the video on
mobile emily maiden asks have you guys
in the u.s seen the cambridge analytica
stuff channel 4 just exposed
i've bookmarked it i've not yet looked
at it i've been preparing for this
stream
because i have so many things to show
you guys in a moment i have a lot of
memes for you
sunil wani says what's your reaction to
republican state legislatures
unilaterally sending their electorates
regardless of votes due to fail
okay so you're sunil we love you but
you're explaining it in a little bit of
a confusing way
the idea is trump would trump would try
to steal the election
by asking state legislatures in states
that biden wins
to send republican electors anyway
on the argument that there was fraud or
fraud
as donald trump likes to say or both in
some cases
um so we have a whole clip out about
that 10 15-minute clip which i encourage
you to check out
jonathan williams says racists are a
dying breed
but that's why they inbreed brutal
brutal brutal
um dylan clutter says do you think the
tax leaks will have any real impact on
the election you know
i so here's the thing my view is i think
that
the tax leaks will have no impact on
99.9
of the electorate but it could be so
close in some states that that point one
actually makes a difference and we're
already seeing you know when i tweeted
yesterday about
the trump tax leaks i had people
say sending me messages on twitter
saying david
his business lost money of course he
didn't pay taxes some years
his business lost money and at the same
time they're saying trump's a genius to
figure out a way not to pay taxes so so
wait a second
is your you're saying the business
genius
lost money it doesn't sound like much of
a business genius does it i mean the
there it's
the responses are incoherent but it goes
to show you that
the i could shoot people on fifth avenue
and not lose support thing
it was essentially true and his base is
not really going to abandon him for this
that doesn't mean you might not see
you know if if 15 000 people who weren't
going to vote in michigan decide to vote
because trump paid no taxes
that could be all you need to flip
michigan so you know i think it's about
um
understanding expectations we have
completed a level five hype train on
twitch already
the the stream has only been going five
minutes and we've completed a level five
hype train which i very much
appreciate we do have um super chat
messages coming in very strongly this is
a great time to send a super chat
if you're watching on youtube i would
love it if you did dinosaur tony says
channel 4 news in the uk
just stared an exclusive on the 2016
trump campaign millions of black voters
marked as deterrence
uh deterrence maybe i'm not
understanding that word i haven't seen
that yet but i am going to look at it
joe sheehan says hey david i'm writing
off this donation to you as a business
consulting fee
thanks for steering me towards the left
my pleasure sounds like a legitimate
deduction
david clarke says david working out
views per day
trump doing taxes yeah it was the
numbers were difficult because
30 million views in a 30-day month
there's a lot of dividing by zero in
that and i struggled with it a little
bit
let me say thank you to marty cummings
marty cummings is new member number one
today at jointpakman.com also
thanks to oh i missed this one von
rollinson von rollinson is new member
number two today
we are of course all and by all i mean
i am hoping that donald trump will get
some
nasty questions today about not paying
taxes
about his previous tweets saying that
others should pay taxes when he wasn't
trump's previous tweet that obama only
paid 20
obama only paid 20 on 700k
in income trump paid 700 bucks
oh i'm sorry do we have a troll that i
have to ban
are there people to ban um
yeah we we do have uh moderators well if
i see anybody i will ban
them it's very common people get banned
in my uh
in my streams unfortunately but it does
happen
oh will trump even take questions maybe
not he might just uh shuffle out of the
room
we we will see okay let me show you guys
just a few different things that you
might be interested in
uh because that there there are some
memes and things you would like this is
a highlight someone made from
my interview with jessie lee peterson
let's see if people like this this is
kind of cool
right now which uh which christian value
do you think donald trump most strongly
embodies
perfect love for who all people
wow wow that's incredible jesse
there you go so that's a nice one that's
a pretty good one number two
a viewer sent this to me this was my
stunned reaction
during an interview the other day about
q anon
and somebody isolated it and this this
definitely has mimetic value so i'm
going to paste the link to this
gif or jiff in the twitch chat
and then i'm going to place paste the
link in the youtube chat in case anybody
wants to make
some memes with this it is i'm making it
available to you
number two another possibility the other
day at my friend's place over the
weekend
i uh i was being chased by two puppies
and i juked them into oblivion
and i feel like this could definitely
have potential for memes as well
take a look at this look at me juke
these guys so i i pivot
then they think that was the juke but
then boom boom boom look at that
footwork the dogs run into each other
and i'm gone i'm 50 yards away
i'm just gone gone they couldn't touch
me so i feel like this could be you know
the dogs could be replaced with trump
look at the dogs there when i juke them
boom they slam into each other and it's
just puppies flying everywhere
and i mean that's a touchdown right i
mean i am gone
after that so um yeah if people i think
there's probably so
i posted this to twitter as well there's
like twitter video downloaders
instagram video downloaders so you guys
can definitely if people want to do
something with this i have a feeling
this could be a treasure trove
a treasure trove of means boom boom boom
there it is and i'm gone
just they did not even stand a chance
there it is and then what else do i have
oh
uh this is going to be the big question
this is
joe biden as me and donald trump as
jessie lee peterson from my recent
debate that i did with jesse lee
peterson this is a transposition
of our faces so this is something nice i
don't know who did this one but i like
it
uh yeah by the way guys people saying
i'm running weird this is a joke the
entire thing is a joke i made a video to
post online
it's all you know it's all just it's i'm
kidding the entire thing is a joke
all right and then somebody found my
doppelganger some guy who was
interviewed for wikitongs
i don't even know what that is they
found my uh
my doppelganger so that's another
interesting one and you can find this
on the david pakman show subreddit if
you are interested
if you are interested do not feel
obligated
but certainly things that are available
to you if you like them
let's see if we have anybody else any
other live streams that are going now
um scheduled for 10 minutes from now
nobody else seems to be live yet alright
so we'll stick around
if somebody does see a channel that is
live please let me know
and i will i will immediately
immediately switch to it
okay um other super chats that are
coming in
let me see here uh oh wait a second
we just lost a bunch of them so many
came in at once let me see
um
i missed a bunch of them look at how
many we
number one incoming dave warning okay uh
wixy bit says number one in covid cases
and deaths usa usa yeah but you got to
look at per capita if we're going to
look at per capita we've got to look at
per capita
timmy lunsford says do you have a plan
for your shows after trump love the show
yeah i i've mentioned this before
there's people who are like what are you
going to do when trump's gone what did
we do before trump was gone we did a
show and we had great growth and
audience engagement so you know every
the the news will always be the news
there's going to be plenty of uh
material
chakaseki says how do you think trump
broke a hondas and don
jr cocahontas will spin this way out of
this one now well
they'll say that the report on their
taxes is fake news
and then hopefully the actual tax
documents will be released i'm hoping
that the new york times is playing coy
letting trump say it's fake and then
releasing the documents
the question will be can the documents
be released in a way that doesn't expose
the source
for the new york times which is what
they want to protect
okay thanks to jewel mac appreciate the
twitch sub
hoa prez shanks has subscribed
apots has subscribed on twitch alluring
lord as well as christopher robin
rando lopez godul red scare mccarthy
hampelman boopy in love
suwanu all sorts of people signing up on
twitch which
you love to see it you really do um
other super chats
love you david okay proton jinx i fear
any debate will be a marathon
of hyperbole trump and platitudes biden
where nothing of substance is said
i believe joe biden is going to bring it
tomorrow i believe joe biden is going to
going to bring substance that's my my
position as of right now
carl simmons says i wanted to show my
support to you for all that you do for
us you are absolutely appreciated by my
wife and i
thank you i i love that david burley
says thanks for what you're doing to get
rid of this maniac
lauren says david you are the only way i
can stomach these press conferences with
sanity
intact thank you well listen if you like
the press briefings
on our channel make sure you're here
tomorrow night for the debate
we will be live live live for the debate
i'm hoping that it is our biggest stream
ever
uh you can be just hit subscribe on
youtube or follow on twitch so that when
we go live tomorrow night for the debate
you'll be notified that's
that's my recommendation you do it
however you want to do it
but uh that's that's what i would
recommend and tomorrow night we will be
here i'll start about a half hour before
the debate
and it's going to be it's going to be an
evening
let me put it that way it's going to be
an evening joseph dinzies says today
is yom kippur time for trump to atone
for his egregious sins donate and phone
bank to democrats today
i just donated 750 dollars to sarah
greenfield yes it is yom kippur
i am not fasting i am culturally jewish
i am ethnically jewish i am
community jewish but
i'm not religious so i am not fasting
today
bad luck james says urgent briefing
meaning binder of biden talking points
to muddy the water been watching all the
live streams thank you for all you're
doing
appreciate it thank you tess
stickles love it your mother was a
hamster
and your father smelt of elderberries
the plot thickens as they say why by the
way
is it a soup metaphor man i don't know
what that is about
parker peter says will the tax article
swing independence
yeah so i addressed that a little bit uh
earlier in the stream
and i will be addressing it in a clip
set to publish to youtube
um in about a half hour i'm going to see
if we have any live
uh video of what is going on here does
anybody know if anybody is live right
now like the hill
trump live is the hill live the hill is
not live
washington post trump live
nope not live we've got uh who else
might be live
now this trump live
nope they are not live i just want to
have a sense of how close we are to the
start
fox news trump live
let's see uh
no they are not live either wow that's
uh that's interesting
msnbc still doing news yeah if anybody
finds a youtube stream where uh we we
could just see what's going on in the
room
let me know and i will switch to it yes
scheduled to start in five minutes
that's absolutely correct
absolutely correct trump may be busy
getting his hair done with your tax
money that's true
that's very very true okay other super
chats coming in
alex since iraq says do you see biden
and trump potentially getting physical
with each other
tomorrow maybe even a fight no i don't
no i don't
um let's see what else we've got
i see dead llama says i think the bigger
story is that literally
that he literally owes hundreds of
millions to various places
who do you think is going to foot the
bill if he wins yeah i addressed that
today
and i am going to address that more
tomorrow uh on the program that's a big
thing these these loans are a big
area of liability bay photo says here's
five bucks for your good work plazman
reporting to the irs optional optional
no listen
you are not going to uh you will never
hear
that i have been um you know defrauding
the irs or anything like that
i am uh we declare all revenues
all revenues i feel very very good about
our relationship with uh with with the
irs
um yeah connor says love your
show keep up the great work david i'm
just wondering as to how the new york
times got these records leak from the
new york d.a hope this is in the
hope this in debate yeah i don't know a
number of different
speculations eric says usa had the
highest ghs index global health security
so we were equipped to have the best
covid response
yet we had among the worst trump blew it
yes indeed yes indeed
zachary monroe says do you think chris
wallace will mention or even talk about
the criminality of trump's taxes during
tomorrow's debate
i don't know if taxes will come up i
really i i don't
i really don't and it depends you know
you have to think about the context in
which they come up
um being one that both candidates can
address
because in debates if you ask a question
that's really meant
for one of the two candidates it will no
doubt be
be called out as you know as biased or
trying to attack one candidate you
really need questions that apply to both
let's see here marco garcia says latinos
in arizona appreciate all the breakdown
on everything happening guys
we are potentially i don't want to say
too much but we are potentially getting
dangerously close
dangerously close to a very big
announcement about
a spanish language a regular spanish
language content that i may be doing i
don't want to say anything else right
now because
the discussion the negotiations are
happening at the highest level
but i may have something to announce
soon
let me put it that way soon okay
it is now almost 3 30 so we should have
somebody going live soon you would
imagine
um white house is live but we don't have
any video
um what else yeah i'm still not seeing
any other live feeds people are acting
like i should be able to find one
but i'm just not able to find one so
we're waiting for this one hoping donald
trump will answer questions about his
taxes
let me um say thanks to a few people on
twitch cipher has subscribed with prime
deflated brady has gifted a subscription
colors atk has subscribed
ryan goldie has subscribed with twitch
a lot of beautiful people subscribing
there let me thank some people for
signing up on my website
nils kolberg is new member number three
today
annette foster is new member number four
joaquin
welch is new member number five
salah zenye is new member number six
ryan dragon is number seven and lars
holtfolt i hope i pronounced that
correctly
is uh is number eight i see people
trying to link it
but the links don't work in twitch chat
if you can just tell me
what what channel it is i can go and
find it
um if you just yeah
i can find it if you tell me what the
link was supposed to be too
for uh for protection we don't allow
links in twitch chat
very powerful protection
but if you describe it i will find it
anybody anybody
where are we at it was just linked
what's the name of the channel the
google okay
that's not that i don't think that's the
right channel
bloomberg okay bloomberg trump live
uh let us see here
bloomberg just making sure it's the
right feed
and then we will bring it my commitment
is to bring you the best possible feed
um ah beautiful
beautiful i appreciate the assist here
it is bloomberg
live excellent excellent excellent
excellent appreciate that
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much everybody
that's how trump wraps these okay good
no that is very good
all right if you're just joining us and
you just want to just a quick refresh of
the fresh memes that i have for you
today we have a couple different ones
we have a short clip from the jessie lee
peterson interview
which uh which christian value do you
think donald trump most
strongly embodies perfect love
for who all people wow
wow that's incredible jesse
so there is that one this is me reacting
to being told
crazy things about q anon that's how i
reacted
and that definitely is something that
could be memed
you can find the link in the chat i
posted it a few times earlier
um and then video from over the weekend
of me juking out some puppies boom boom
boom there it is
and then look at that fancy footwork
with the ankles the puppy's just gone
and there i was just they could they
didn't stand a chance
and then chasing after me so a lot a lot
of stuff for you guys there
um yeah and then i think i had one oh
yeah and then my doppelganger my
doppelganger is this dude who i guess
works for wiki tongues
it does there is a resemblance there i
feel like i have a better hairline than
this guy at least for now
um so it's a bit a bit of an insult but
i think it's okay
not gonna not gonna be mad at anybody
too too much
all right other super chats are
continuing to come in we love
super chat robert haven says you can't
tell me trump is a good businessman when
he
spent 72 grand a year to have his hair
like a merkin
on a roman lady of the night you would
think if you spend 70 grand on hair it
would look better that's true
nathan shocker says david what can we do
to fix the disparity of 30 republican
senators
representing less than that of the
population of california which has two
democratic senators
yes i have a clip on my youtube channel
from the weekend where i point out
there are all of these mechanisms that
fundamentally tilt the country against
the left
despite the country on the issues being
more left than ever
abortion gay marriage taxation health
care etc we have
uh gerrymandering and the urban rural
divide which helps republicans
we have the electoral college system
which helps republicans
democrats haven't become president
despite losing the popular vote
many republicans have and we have the
undemocratic senate
where california gets two senators and
wyoming gets two senators
whereas california has 30 million people
and wyoming has
is it even a million is it like 800 000
i don't even remember
how many people uh wyoming has so yeah
there's a whole bunch of these
mechanisms
bounce world order says the tax dodging
wouldn't hurt him with the base
you're probably right you're probably
right
danino or is that dano says
david pakman is a power bottom come on
guys you know the homophobic stuff it's
like
give me a break whoa
oh my god that what was that that was
crazy
some kind of audio test apparently
happening on bloomberg
it's still going yeah so we're going to
mute that for you guys we don't need
that
we certainly don't need that that's the
last thing i need right now
just go travel says why waste time right
on this channel with 1 million members
and
at the speed messages comes in nobody
read the messages
super chat message is the way to go yes
yes yes
clarence wheeler says harris just said
we're wearing our notorious big shirts
instead of
rbg shirts still doesn't compare to all
of trump's ridiculousness
okay very good nicholas
delia says thank you for all of your
hard work
appreciate that kyle hopper says whoops
we lost kyle hopper
where did that go kyle hopper says if
trump had paid
10 cents a tweet in 2019 it'd be moored
more i don't know what that means
jeez tom mcbrierty says just became a
soy boy love you bro you're an american
treasure and true patriot keep doing
what you do thank you i like that thanks
tom
thanks to crayon eater crayon eater has
grabbed a twitch prime subscription
dj panda killox as well
very much appreciate it uh i am i am
flattered that we have a combined total
right now
um of 22 000 people watching this live
stream
across various platforms
it is uh it's just it's amazing it's
really amazing and i so appreciate
everybody's support i really do
uh nicholas silva says david how could
anyone call you beta
with that incredible display of
athleticism the puppies didn't stand a
chance
yeah i mean look does this look like a
beta to you guys
yeah there you go
anyway uh cool
cool story bro love it all right and by
the way i was wearing converse all stars
for crying out loud who can possibly run
in those
ryan clark says my girlfriend and i
recently found your channel and really
enjoy your content
rational articulate conversations are a
rarity
these days thank you ryan i appreciate
that
as it looks like we are getting closer
and closer to the start of this very
important update from donald trump
uh hey i do want to ask folks a favor
particularly as we get ready
so we took not last week but the
previous week off the reason we did that
is
we're going straight through i mean just
powerfully straight through uh to the
election
um and that starts today oh god betsy
devos is here that's really not not good
tomorrow night we have the debate i want
to ask you to get a membership on my
website at joinpackman.com
okay now disclaimer you can tune out
from the next 30 seconds if you dislike
me
if you're an anti-semite if you're an
anti-yo
semonite if you think what i'm doing is
trash
if you're a hatred get the hell out of
here okay
and if you just don't have them a couple
bucks then for this is not for you
because we want to do the show for
everybody
but if you've got a couple bucks a month
grab a membership on my website
okay it's the most stable funding source
for us
pays for equipment staff salaries health
insurance
all of these things two bucks a month if
you use the coupon code above my head
if you pay for the year at a time it's
like a dollar eighty a month
now if you hear a dollar eighty a month
and you say david i can't afford that
then it is not for you i am not asking
for anybody's last dollar
we're here for you for free no matter
what okay
but if a dollar am a month sounds
interesting to you if it's compelling in
some way
grab a membership we will start to fill
up this blue bar as people sign up we're
at eight right now
the initial goal is 25 maybe we would go
50.
maybe we'd go 75 maybe we'd go 100 we
don't know
um and the coupon code 2020 now it's
just an instant chop of 66
off and people really love it people
really love it from what i read
if you are anti-vegemite can you do a
membership
yeah yeah that's fine i have no problem
with that
and all diet all dietary
configurations are welcome very very
much welcome to be to be members for
sure no
no hesitation there all right
other super chats coming in stephen
parney says hey david you mentioned that
two senators etc was a giveaway to
sparsely populated republican states
so to extend that logic isn't the
supreme court also basically a giveaway
to republicans as well
oh because they're confirmed by the
senate yeah well in
in a sense yeah it's a i'd have to think
about that it's not a perfect analogy
but it's interesting
telengard asks if i've seen tank girl
i have not i have not
yair says the comey rule it's good yeah
that's with michael kelly
right from um uh house of cards is that
on hbo i've not i don't have hbo
interestingly enough but um
[Music]
i've heard that it's very very good
nobody knows okay good very good caitlin
bernal
says hi david just subscribe to your
channel love your content what are your
general predictions for the debate
um i have really no idea i don't know
which
so i don't know which version of trump
will show up will it be upper trump or
downer trump i expect upper trump
and what will biden's approach be will
biden take an aggressive approach will
biden take a
sort of buttoned-up elder statesman
approach it it's really going to come
down to strategy
uh okay what else do we have going on
here
we oh there's admiral gerard
i like it when someone calls there's
people who pronoun there's a funny way
to pronounce his last name
it's like jewel i forget exactly but
kaylee magnani pronounces it in some
wild way it's really something else
uh i i think um i want to see biden be
aggressive but controlled
because when biden gets mad it's when
the stutter comes through
and where he sometimes um loses his
train of thought
so i want biden to be aggressive but
with
prepared aggression rather than reacting
and or maybe overreacting in the moment
that's my uh that that's my
sort of general assessment there okay
um wow there's 139 people browsing the
membership page right now
we could be very close to an explosive
number above my head
explosive thanks to trey didon who is
new
twitch subscriber number 888 888
also thanks to orjic who was subscriber
887
i appreciate that other super chats
coming in
zachary foster do you believe it's
possible they have a couple more
bombshells on trump in the next 40 days
yeah
when i saw that the new york times
published the the tax story
in september rather than in october
october surprise
my belief is that there is more coming
yeah i don't know what
but i would be shocked if there is not
more dustin brown says everyone go check
out early voting procedures if it is
your plan to do so deadlines are fast
approaching yes
here is the page this is the um
where is it uh get your absentee ballot
okay this is the page right here my
friends
this tells you everything you need to
know about getting your absentee ballot
i'm gonna paste the link in twitch chat
because guys we're not just here for the
memes not all of us anyway
we're here to actually try to get
something done this website
vote.org absentee hyphen ballot will
tell you everything you need to know
about in your state
okay about how to register to vote by
mail let's imagine my name was
uh you know what what's what's my name
let's let's imagine it's uh
you know nathaniel bergstrom
and i live at 11 000 wilshere
uh in uh you know sharon massachusetts
perfect and i was born on january
10th 1986
and you know my email address
there we go all right so then it'll tell
me
something went wrong okay well very good
so the website validates addresses
that's the important thing to know
that's a great website that's a great
website use it
understand how to request an absentee
ballot
in your state understand early voting
in your state you can already uh
start voting in some places okay very
very important
very very important
arbuckle says republicans were preparing
their strategy to fight bernie
after the obama warrant coup they didn't
update and kept the socialist
boludez with biden yeah bolules is a
very argentinian term i don't know if
people will get that we could i guess
call it nonsense
or idiocy baked baking says i'm living
with parents i work
emote i'm guessing that's i work remote
oh hold on here's trump all right we
will get to that let's see
what uh this hasn't started this hasn't
started let's see what mango has for us
today
thank you very much oh my god all right
well that's obviously not gonna work
we're gonna have to wait until the white
house stream starts it's usually about
15 seconds by that that noise is crazy
expansion in our test
that's not going to work um the white
house feed
you would imagine is going to start very
very soon
sometimes it's like as much as 30
seconds behind
and then okay here's pbs before last
week we crossed a historic milestone
when the united states conducted our 100
million
tests oh my god accompanied by the vice
president
and uh actually second seems to be
india we're good with 1.5 billion people
and the numbers would be
probably at least 50 million more tests
by us
we've conducted more tests than the
entire european union and
more than uh all of latin america
combined
we're thrilled to be joined by vice
president mike pence secretary of health
and human services
alex azar the entire european union
there we go
more than uh all of latin america
combined
we're thrilled to be joined by vice
president mike pence secretary of health
and human services
alex azar secretary of education
betsy devos i believe oh god she's
probably administrator for the centers
for medicine and
medicaid services seema verma she's
horrible too
and admiral juwah there it is done such
an incredible job
we're also joined by mississippi
governor tate greaves
had a tremendous victory we're so proud
of you
and as well by abbott ceo robert ford
robert thank you very much great job
today i'm pleased to report that we're
announcing our plan to distribute 150
million abbott rapid point of care tests
in the coming weeks very very soon
this will be more than double the number
of i remember him saying that in april
and here's our plan 50 million tests
will go to protect the most vulnerable
communities
which we've always promised to do
including 18 million for nursing homes
15 million for assisted living
facilities
10 million for home health and hospice
care hospitals hospice care agencies and
nearly
trump seems to have contoured makeup
today i've never seen him look this way
not that i care but it is just again
remember we're praying paying for that
he deducts those costs
100 million rapid point-of-care tests
will be given to states and territories
to support
efforts to reopen their economies and
schools immediately and fast as they can
for example the support my
administration is providing
would allow every state to on a very
regular basis
test every teacher who needs it this
continues our critical effort to use
testing to protect high-risk communities
these new abbott rapid point of care
tests are easy to use and return results
within just minutes
you'll have a result at a maximum 15
minutes
machine no machine is required to
process them so
in the old days when we just started
this you remember we'd go out and
we'd have to find these massive
laboratories with tremendously expensive
equipment now we're
down to something that you'll see that
is really
from a different planet yep uh i would
like to ask
admiral gerard to come up and
demonstrate how
these tests are performed he'll do this
very nicely i think
good luck hope you don't test positive
he's going to schwab himself
so thank you mr president uh as of today
the nation
has performed over 111 million tests for
the virus causing kovid
on 13 separate days we have achieved
tests over 1 million per day
and our average test numbers are now
approximately 920
000 per day we are now at an inflection
point in testing
now we now have available on average
three million tests per day
not counting pool testing which could
multiply that number several fold
nearly half of our current tests are
rapid point of care
all of the actions of your
administration including aggressive use
of multiple titles of the dpa
hundreds of millions of dollars in hhs
and dod investments
and regulatory flexibility including
over 200
fda emergency use authorizations clia
enforcement discretion
and application of the prep act have led
us to this
inflection feels like april which brings
us why we're here today
yeah why are we on august 27th after
months of planning and only after one
day after the fda authorization
the trump administration awarded a
contract for 760 million
dollars to abbott for the delivery of a
hundred and fifty million
lucrative finance now rapid test
buy now the binax now detects the
presence of the covet antigen
it uses a specific nasal swab and that
looks okay that swab comes with the test
and it's made by purity
and the reason why puritan swabs are
here is because the administration used
the dpa
in 120 million dollars in investment to
make these swabs able
for to use by having it does not require
an instrument to determine the result
it's 15 it's in 15 minutes the result
there's the audio
testing may be performed by laboratories
with a clear certificate of waiver
this is not a home test but during the
health emergency
sema verma and cms permits laboratories
to extend their certificate
to operate in temporary sites like
schools or churches
or parking lots so though i we
anticipate that the test will
generally be performed by a trained
individual on a patient it's like it
turns out trump
owes people 400 million and paid no
taxes for 10 years
so they put together this dog and pony
show now which is indistinguishable from
one from april
easier it starts with six drops of
liquid onto this piece of paper
one two three four
five can you imagine six
and then there's a nasal swab and again
this is uh
this is not the deep brain biopsy that
we talk about
uh this will generally done by a
healthcare provider but it can be done
supervised it's this easy
one two three four five one two
three four five admiral juwah into the
test
twisted three times
the adhesive is pulled off and you wait
15 minutes
and that is the test and if you get two
lines you're pregnant yes
this is a very sophisticated little
piece of cardboard with lots of
antibodies and incredible technology
into that
we've already shipped 65 000 of these to
disaster operations in california oregon
texas and louisiana
actually have already shipped 2.1
million tests
to 7 600 nursing homes over 900 000
tests to assisted living
300 000 tested the indian health service
and 339
000 tests to historically black colleges
and university
today we start the shipment of a hundred
million tests to governors
beginning with a total of 6.5 million
tests this week to be shipped this week
this is an addition to the continuing
support to other priorities like nursing
homes
allocation to states and territories is
based strictly on their relative
population governors have the
flexibility to use these tests
as they deem fit but we strongly
encourage governors
to utilize them in settings that are
uniquely in need of rapid low-tech
point-of-care tests
like opening and keeping open our k-12
schools
supporting critical infrastructure and
first responders
responding to outbreaks specifically in
certain demographics or locations
it seems like now they're figuring out
it's good to test
mr president we just completed a
briefing to the governors and their
state health officials from the sit room
and we heard words like game changer for
their states
thank you mr president for your
leadership and support of all our
efforts to defeat this virus
thank you very much admiral and let me
ask you uh governor reeves do you
uh do you agree would you like to say
something uh-oh
agree with what
thank you mr president for your
leadership
through this pandemic and through this
crisis
this is it was said by republicans and
democrats alike
earlier this is a game changer in our
state of mississippi our k-12 schools
have been
open for nine weeks our institutions of
higher learning have been open
for about the same see how they're doing
while we have
testing available now at least once a
week
in every county of our state what this
allocation is going to allow for us is
we will have
testing available for our k through 12
teachers every single day going forward
and the thing that we know not a
disaster
and secretary devos knows this so well
kids learn so much better when they're
in the classroom
than when they're doing distance
learning or hybrid
and while we have 75 to 80 percent of
our kids back in the classroom we want
to get a hundred percent of our kids
back in the classroom it is also
incredibly important mr president your
decision to allocate
on the front end to the historically
black colleges and universities
means the world to mississippi our
larger institutions have the financial
resources
to provide testing but in mississippi
with jackson state university and alcorn
univer
alcorn state university and mississippi
valley state university three of our
eight institutions of higher learning
will get an allocation of these tests
and it's going to make a difference
and kids all across our state are going
to be better served because of it and i
want to personally thank you
on behalf of the residents of
mississippi for doing this mr president
thank you
what a guy very much thank you great job
in a short period of time my
administration has built the most
advanced testing system in the world
there's never been anything like this
when the pandemic struck
there were zero tests for the china
virus well yeah it was a new virus
all of america's resources to achieve
these
unparalleled capabilities we slashed red
tape and approved
emergency use authorizations for
243 type of tests that's how many tests
we have
i invoked the defense production act and
related authorities more than 100 times
and distributed
171 million dollars to expand testing
production
we've done nearly twice as much testing
per capita as france
italy and germany and over six times
more testing
and why do we have so many tests and
death cases and deaths per capita than
them that's weird
three times two three four five or six
we performed nearly 40 million more
tests than india and
by the end of next month we will have
over 100 million tests available in the
market
more than half will be point of care
tests those are the quick ones and
they're really the ones that have the
best impact
with the results in less than 15 minutes
we've also
prioritized resources for the votes most
vulnerable including nursing home
residents we delivered rapid testing
devices to nearly 14
000 certified nursing homes we opened
over one thousand community testing
sites in low income communities nobody
could have done this we invested
in unprecedented only every other
country
tribal communities have the tests and
resources they need
to combat the virus and it's important
to remember that as younger and
healthier people return to work
and as we massively increase testing
capacity
we will identify more cases and
asymptomatic individuals
in low-risk populations oh so now he
wants this should not cause undue alarm
the total
number of cases is not the full metric
of success
hospitalization capacity and mortality
rates are far
more instructive metrics
as we do more tests you're going to have
automatically more cases
here we go we are relentlessly focused
on protecting the vulnerable while
enabling healthy americans to go back to
work
we can do both as florida and arizona
and other states have
recently shown over the last eight weeks
hospitalizations have declined by 48
percent
and they've just reached the lowest
point since march it's a long time
ago due to advances in treatment
the fatality rate has fallen 85 since
april
our excess mortality has been
considerably lower than comparable i
think what's going on is that he's
probably been spray tanned for the
debate tomorrow or like this this his
physical appearance must have something
to do with the upcoming debate
is my guess in a normal year this is a
critical measurement because it includes
undetected giant virus deaths along with
deaths
resulting from lockdowns and lockdowns
can be very harmful
remember that there are very few deaths
that have been able to be identified as
resulting from the lockdowns despite
what he says
europe has experienced a 50 percent
greater excess mortality rate during the
virus than the
us and their economic contraction has
been far
more severe under operation warp speed
my administration is on track to deliver
a safe and effective vaccine in record
time
we're doing very well with the vaccines
as most of you know
four vaccines are now in the final stage
of trials
the day the vaccine is approved by the
fda will begin distributing it
within 24 hours with hundreds of
millions of doses
to follow very quickly we're all set to
go we're
all ready and logistically we're we have
the military lined up and some
incredible people are just waiting to
have it
over 100 million doses will be available
before the end of the year
we will defeat the virus and we will end
the pandemic
and next year will be one of the
greatest years in our history and we
think it's going to be a very exciting
period of time
with that i'd like to ask mike to say a
few words because you would just left a
task force meaning
he's gonna get out of here without
taking questions isn't he he seems to be
he seems to be like kind of like this is
the last thing he's gonna do it
thank you mr president
this is a historic day what and other
than the day
that i believe will come soon that
america
produces the first safe and effective
vaccine could be british
what's announced today with the
distribution of 150 million
rapid point of care tests all across
america it's a testament to your
leadership mr president how is this a
historic day
to this great team that you've assembled
from secretary azar
admiral girard and others it's a
testament to the partnership that we
forge with governors like governor
reeves
all across america and it's a testament
to great companies like
abbott laboratories and the thousands of
employees who
mr president i know have literally
worked around the clock
he literally gave the speech 50 times
mostly in april may and june
and the greatest research companies in
america
and said that we need medicines known as
therapeutics we need a vaccine for
america but you also challenge them
to develop a rapid point-of-care test
that could be distributed all across
america and enable us more effectively
slow the spread
flatten the curve protect the vulnerable
and save lives
and mr president today's announcement is
really emblematic of the public-private
partnership that you forged
it is emblematic which is announce the
same thing once a week for six months
and pretend it's progress
today with the nation's governors the
white house coronavirus task force
completed our 38th
conference call with america's governors
but all along the way from our very
first meeting you made it clear that
we'd spare no expense of the federal
government the full resource of the
federal government you made available
to put the health of america first but
you also
challenged us and you challenged
american industry to being the full
power and innovation
of the american economy to bear on this
moment right
and whether it be uh ppe where we forged
a partnership to see to the delivery the
manufacturer
of hundreds of millions of personal
protective equipment
whether it be how we started with 15 000
ventilators in the strategic national
stockpile and today in partnership with
ge healthcare ford and general motors we
have over 150 000
ventilators in the strategic national
stockpile
whether it be the extraordinary progress
on therapeutics
remdessevier convalescent plasma that
are literally saving lives or whether it
be as you reflected mr president on our
steady
progress toward achieving a safe and
effective vaccine before the end of this
year
it's been that public-private
partnership that you've led
that's made these advances a possible
and on testing the american people
really deserve to know that when we
began as you said mr president it was
literally a standing start
we didn't have information on the coding
of the coronavirus until
mid-february but america's
cdc labs and public health labs did
their level best
and by the end of february we'd done
less than 10 000 coronavirus tests
pence is doing the sur routine a few
moments ago last week we cleared 100
million
tests all across the country it's
extraordinary we have the capacity to do
three million
tests a day it's a testament to american
innovation and the leadership
that you've provided also mr president
we've
delivered to nearly 14 000 nursing homes
in america point-of-care tests already
that are making it possible for us to
really keep focus
on the most vulnerable as you know only
eight percent
of those who have contracted the
coronavirus
are in nursing homes but 40 percent of
those
that have lost their life have been in
nursing homes and so we've surged those
resources
and surged them to vulnerable
populations
but with the announcement today this
abbott laboratories buy next now test
we began a process first announcing 50
million tests
to go to our vulnerable communities they
begin a process of subsequent
announcements and announcements and
announcements we told all the nation's
governors today
we begin the process this week of
distributing 100 million
tests to each state and territory in the
country free of charge
so they can begin to deploy those tests
to
on the priorities that the state has set
but mr president given the extraordinary
capacity that we have in testing today
we
we expressed a hope to all the governors
today that they would particularly use
these abbott binax tests to
open up america's schools and to keep
them open
and we heard about the enthusiasm it's
almost like now that stuff depends on
testing to open
they're like let's get tests to people
will mean in
in helping to process helping to process
the testing that will get our kids into
school and keep our kids
in school mr president let me just close
by saying this is a
we've passed through a challenging time
in the life of this nation in 2020 in
our hearts
i know your heart is with all the
families that have suffered loss
empathetic guys but as you said
cases are declining hospitalizations
have been declining
declining dramatically particularly in
the sun belt
in louisiana where not long ago 50
parishes had
more than 10 percent positivity rate now
only three parishes
are testing positive over 10 percent
arizona was testing 20
positivity rate now now it's less than 4
percent consistently
but with cases and positivity rising in
10 states
in the midwest and the near west
and with this historic advance in
testing that's being distributed
150 strong around the country mr
president the american people
should anticipate that that cases will
rise
in the days ahead but as we
as we more readily identify those who've
contracted
the coronavirus the american people can
be confident because of this
extraordinary and historic
public and private partnership that
you've forged because of this
whole of government approach we're ready
as we prove through the outbreak in the
sun belt this summer
we'll make sure that any community any
state that's impacted with rising cases
any school
that's impacted we'll have the ppe we'll
have the supplies we'll have the
medicines
and as you said mr president we will
continue
at your direction our relentless drive
toward achieving the first safe and
effective vaccine so we can achieve the
day
that we once and for all put this
coronavirus in the past so
mr president with thanks to our industry
partners thanks to this team
is he rapping well thanks to you for
your strong leadership uh i hope for
that day
and the american people can be confident
we will not rest
what a historic day until we put this
coronavis
here thank you very much mike uh scott
atlas would you say
a few words please as to how we're doing
and not out where you see us going
please neuroradiologist scott atlas will
tell us how to deal with a pandemic
okay thank you mr president and uh i
also want to echo the congratulations to
the team
uh the task force admiral gerwar in
particular
very hard on the testing this is a
remarkable day because we have state of
the art testing this is not the typical
point of care test even this is new
this is does not require any kind of
machine it's very rapid
and this is not one of those deep swab
things that people are uh reluctant to
use so i think we're
we're really making an advance here to
do what testing is supposed to do
and that's to save lives uh as the vice
president mentioned we know that there
are areas of the country that have more
cases this is to be expected with more
social mingling and uh the testing
uh but particularly protect you have a
pandemic do you go to the infectious
disease guy or a neuroradiologist
trick question depends which one sucks
up to you terrible people not just
inside nursing homes but in residential
settings and senior day care centers
this is a remarkable advance and i
anticipate that as
as this virus as we get toward the end
of this pandemic
and the vaccine is being developed as
quickly as it has been
america will be in a different position
and there really should be as i've said
many times
the fear is not the issue here we really
have a handle on what's going on
we know what to anticipate and there's
remarkable advances being made as we see
today
thank you very much wow thank you very
much tremendous progress is being made
and
i say it i'll say it all the time we're
rounding the corner
and very importantly vaccines are coming
but we're rounding the corner regardless
right but vaccines are coming and
they're coming fast we have four great
companies already and
it's going to be added to very rapidly
uh they're
in final stages of testing and from what
we're hearing the
results are going to be very
extraordinary so
thank you very much i appreciate it and
thank you very much great job by abbott
right from the beginning great job by
abbott
thank you thank you very much everybody
thank you
donald trump coming and going without
taking a single question
and of course reporters shouting out
questions about trump's taxes but donald
trump
retreating back into the white house we
learned very little today my friends
tomorrow night though
trump may actually have to answer real
questions tomorrow night is the first
debate with joseph r biden jr
we will be live right here on youtube on
twitch on facebook
make sure to subscribe for free on
youtube to be notified tomorrow when we
go live with debate coverage i would
love for you to be here and watch it
with me
don't watch it with fox news come on
guys subscribe and watch it with me if
you're watching on
facebook give us a like you'll be
notified when we go live if you're
watching on twitch
give us a follow you will be notified
tomorrow evening when we go
live live live with the debate
it is going to be quite a day
quite a day that does it for me my
friends we will be back with you
tomorrow
with a podcast youtube clips a members
only bonus show
and and and and that
first debate live stream i will see you
then
you